what seems to be happening to me is that
not only do they get all the gold but
they get all the bloody unearned moral
virtue because now they have the gold
and they think well i'm going to atone
for my sins by what by standing forward
for equity now that i've made a fortune
and by what uh trying to save the planet
by decarbonizing it despite the fact
that my industries at least in principle
by my own standards contributed to that
it's not even their money
it's the money of everyday citizens in
that democratic society which has been
aggregated in the hands of these small
institutions
that are using the money of other people
to advance social and political agendas
through the market
that most of the owners of capital
actually disagree with so in certain
sense there's a large-scale breach of
trust here
welcome to episode 160 of my podcast i'm
michaela peterson i had my dad jordan
peterson and vivek ramaswamy on for this
episode i heard about vivek through a
mutual friend because of his book woke
inc where he talked about esgs he's on
today to discuss esgs and his new book
which is out now linkedin show notes
called nation of victims esgs are
something that everyone should know
about when i was opening for dad's shows
i was actually talking about them
because i think it's one of the most
important topics that people should be
discussing now it's an acronym that
discusses how people who have control
over companies like blackrock are
influencing policies that are
contributing to issues like massive
energy shortages this is really serious
we trust companies to do what's in a
company's best interest you can trust
that the ceo of a corporation is going
to be greedy to make his company worth
more that's at least trustworthy what
you can't trust are ceos who are not
elected banding together deciding they
know what direction society needs to
take then influencing how companies
operate in order to push society in that
direction and the worst part is most
people don't know this is happening or
what the outcomes are this kind of setup
is not how america was built it's not
even capitalism really so i wanted dad
on in this episode and i didn't do much
talking really it was mostly listening
and learning
vivek's a former technology and biotech
entrepreneur and his most recent venture
is an asset management company that's
very interesting called strive vivek
founded strive to promote excellence
capitalism which he hopes will offer a
better alternative to the popular and
very destructive esg model of asset
management which like i said is
deeply and largely responsible for
europe's growing energy crisis
in this episode we discussed and defined
what esg is we discussed the asset
management company blackrock and its
founder larry fink
the revival of civic duty in the west
the dangers of too much centralization
optimal resistance the invitation to
play and much more before we jump into
this episode this episode of the podcast
is sponsored by rabbit air each year
since 2009 inc magazine has consistently
rated rabbit air as one of the fastest
growing companies in the us
for a good reason they make air
purifiers actually
right here
it's usually snuck off to the side
look at it glow
it's gonna focus back there there's my
beautiful couch too uh anyway there it
is back there they make air purifiers
which is something i've used since i was
a kid but they were always clunky and
loud and made me feel like a dork i've
always had trouble with allergies which
is you guys probably already know but my
tree allergies are so insane that
recently i had to move from tennessee to
florida so i could breathe and function
normally again i had bronchitis off and
on for six months which was awful
i would have suffered a lot more
honestly if it wasn't for the air
purifiers i had around my house from
rabbit air their latest innovation the
a3 ultra quiet air purifier won the
ifidea
good design
and the world's most prestigious red dot
design award thanks to the stylish
design and the advanced filtration
technology that targets airborne
allergens particles and odors
effectively
we breathe in almost 2000 gallons of air
a day
and most americans spend their days
inside it's a lot of potential mold tree
pollen and dust that you're breathing in
especially if you have pets
or live in tennessee
if you wake up congested or you have
kids that wake up with a stuffy nose or
if you just want to sleep better i would
recommend going to rabbitaire.com
today
to see their models or call them 24 7 to
speak to a rabbit air consultant that's
r a b b i t
a i r.com they're the brand i use and
i'm super picky about brands i use and
about health i hope you enjoy this
episode
vivek ramaswamy and
dad jordan peterson welcome to my
podcast
it's good to be on
looking forward to it
vivek uh before we get started can you
give a brief background about who you
are and what it is you do
yeah so i was uh born and raised in
cincinnati ohio not far from home in
columbus ohio where i am today i began
my career as an entrepreneur i had
studied molecular biology and undergrad
at harvard i thought i was going to be a
scientist on an academic track i ended
up getting into the world of biotech
investing at a hedge fund from 2007 to
2014 where i co-managed a biotech
portfolio spent three of those years in
law school at yale thought i was going
to be interested in law and political
philosophy scratching an itch that i had
as a as a long-time scientist
i ended up leaving my career as an
investor though in 2014 to start a
biotech company called roivent which i
built as ceo for seven years
we developed a number of medicines five
of them are fda approved products today
but i stepped down from my career as a
biotech ceo and i thought i was done
with my business career uh when i
stepped down to write a pair of books
woke inc and nation of victims the most
recent one and i've you know been
writing in the wall street journal
producing scholarship on issues relating
to stakeholder capitalism and the esg
movement i thought that was going to be
my future in writing and and possibly
dare i say thought leadership in this
particular area that was a passion of
mine
but i was called back to the world of
entrepreneurship in part by my own
writing
highlighting a problem was was somewhat
important but i thought that addressing
the problem was was even more important
and that led me to start the latest
company that i'm now leading which is
strive and it's a new asset management
firm that's competing against companies
like blackrock and other leaders in the
so-called esg and stakeholder capitalism
movement and so that's made this a very
busy year with a new book and a new
company and hopefully hopefully reviving
what i think of as as excellence in our
economy and our culture in the process
okay that was fantastic i think before
we get into this conversation you should
describe to people who don't know
exactly what esg stands for and what it
means for people
yeah that's a that's a good
table stakes point because the
definition keeps changing even by its
biggest proponents so i think it's
important we flash freeze it so we can
talk about it whether or not we agree
yeah esg stands for environmental social
and governance factors
influencing the allocation of capital in
global capital markets okay that's a
mouthful well that's a close cousin of a
broader movement
called stakeholder capitalism which
refers to the basic idea that businesses
should not just focus on selling
products and services for a profit
but that they should also advance other
social agendas and societal interests
that sounds benign enough now this was
designed as a contrast to the worldview
advanced by milton friedman in the 1970s
and 1980s where he said no the right
purpose of a business is exclusively to
focus on selling products and services
for profit to maximize value for
shareholders and the thing that milton
friedman worried about was that if
companies didn't do that they'd be less
effective at making widgets and the size
of the economy would shrink and everyone
would lose out
as you know we can get into this but
my critique of this trend is actually
quite different than milton friedman's
my main concern is not just that it
threatens the effectiveness of american
capitalism or the effectiveness of
corporations though i believe all that's
true
my bigger concern is that the esg
movement and this broader philosophy of
stakeholder capitalism
actually threatens democracy because
democracy is a system built on the idea
that everyone's voice and vote counts
equally on questions ranging from
climate change to addressing racial
injustice whatever the right answers may
be those are the political questions
that a democracy settles through free
speech and open debate into public
square
and it's my view that what the esg
movement demands and what the
stakeholder capitalist movement demands
is that actually we take those questions
out of the political process and settle
them through the use of capital force in
boardrooms across america and across the
west more broadly and i think that's a
betrayal of of the democratic system
that we built in 1776 in this side of
the ocean
but uh but even more broadly a betrayal
of of a system of self-governance of
free agents in in a free society
let me ask you if you don't mind a
couple of questions pertaining to
esg
uh three i would say
it isn't obvious that if the
focus of return
switches to the stakeholders let's say
the broader stakeholders that doesn't
mean something like
i have a particular ideological agenda
and uh it's the moral one and because of
that you should subordinate your company
to me
rather than
say dedicating it towards these
hypothetical social legit this
hypothetical social agenda and interests
so the first question might be just
exactly what are those
hypothetical broader social
interests and who determines what they
are
and then on the friedman side
you know i've always been curious about
this because friedman's notion was that
a company should maximize shareholder
value and my issue with that as a
research psychologist was always
well maximized shareholder value over
what time period
because if it's quarterly returns that
looks a hell of a lot different than
it's if it's if it's a pension fund and
it's a 20-year investment horizon and
that's very much relevant to the issue
let's say of the sustainability that the
esg
power mongers hypothetically are working
to promote so the first question is
what are these social agendas and
interests and why is it that some
arbitrary third party let's say should
be able to set what those are i know
that your concerns pertain to that to
some degree
oh to a large degree actually so
you're getting right to the heart of the
most important questions here which is
great i mean look i think that the the
questions that are the prime
targets of the esg movement today
generally relate to staving off global
climate change
and delivering equity to rectify what
they view as historical group
identity-based injustices racial and
gender-based and sexual orientation
based those are when you think about the
e and the s the environmental and the
social prong which are really doing most
of the work here the g is just a nice
little add-on at the end
it's really it's really mostly related
to staving off global global climate
change through decarbonization and
achieving global equity both between
different identity driven groups based
on race or gender or sexual orientation
and also even transnational equity which
actually relates to the first agenda of
staving off global climate change so
those two things work in concert but the
question is who gets to decide and i
think that's actually that's actually
the biggest and most mysterious question
of all it turns out that that it's it's
the answer that question is is one of
the principles that i have revived in my
first book which is the principle of the
golden rule not the golden rule that uh
that most people know that you treat
people like you want to be treated in
return now the golden rule that says
that he who has the gold makes the rules
which is to say that the people who
control the largest swaths of capital
are the ones who make the you know
unilateral decisions as to which
questions hypothetically hypothetically
that would be fine if the rules they
were making pertain to their capital but
what seems to be happening to me is that
not only do they get all the gold but
they get all the bloody unearned moral
virtue because now they have the gold
and they think well i'm going to atone
for my sins by what by standing forward
for equity now that i've made a fortune
and by what uh trying to save the planet
by decarbonizing it despite the fact
that my industries at least in principle
by my own standards contributed to that
so so much to say there i think first
though we have to pause on on whose goal
they're actually holding
so this is very different than the john
d rockefeller j.p morgan andrew carnegie
era where it was their own goal and they
would wield it to advance not only
market power but certain forms of
political power and that's one debate
and we can get to that debate
my biggest beef is actually even simpler
than that what's happened for in the
21st century is that for example let's
just take the three largest asset
managers in the united states blackrock
state street and vanguard those three
institution wheel institutions will not
tens of billions or even hundreds of
billions of dollars or even trillions of
dollars but tens of trillions of dollars
21 trillion dollars just in the hands of
those three institutions half of that 21
trillion almost in the hands of one
yet here's the rub
it's not even their money
it's the money of everyday citizens in
that democratic society who has been
aggregated by the hands of which has
been aggregated in the hands of these
small institutions that are using the
money of other people
to advance social and political agendas
through the market
that most of the owners of capital
actually disagree with so in certain
sense there's a large scale breach of
trust here even if you even if you
accepted that the guys who have the gold
get to make the rules if it's their own
gold that's a proposition we can itself
debate the funny part here is it's not
even their gold so that's the betrayal
at the heart of the modern esd system
and you ask the question of who gets to
decide the answer is it's a small
handful of actors people like larry fink
the ceo of blackrock and you know does
larry think worth a billion dollars or
whatever sure he is but he's not worth
21 trillion dollars he's using 21
trillion dollars or 10 trillion dollars
in blackrock's case of other people's
money most of whom don't even know that
he's doing it and most of whom don't
even know that he's using it to advance
social and political agendas that most
of those people disagree with now let's
get to the deeper question that you
raised though is look if you earned a
lot of money or aggregated a lot of
market power presumably it was by market
judgments that give you standing to
decide which products rise to the top
whether this jacket or a different
jacket or this phone or a different
phone rise to the top that's not a one
person one vote system and i don't think
it should be that's a one dollar one
vote system but if you're talking about
how to settle how and whether to address
global climate change through higher
prices for goods versus lower carbon
emissions or racial equity through quota
systems or some other means
those are not the kinds of questions
that one ought to settle through the use
of capital force because there's no
greater standing for larry fink or
anyone else to have a superior view as a
citizen on the answer to that question
those are the kinds of questions where
everyone's voice and vote ought to in my
opinion count equally regardless of the
number of dollars they wield in the
marketplace unadjusted by the number of
dollars they control and that's the
perversion at the heart of this system
so there's really two perversions one is
it's the use of other people's money not
their own money and they're actually
using other people's money who mostly
disagree with the agendas they're
advancing but the second perversion is
the the nature of the question it's a
question of the wrong kind that they're
using capital force to settle when in a
democratic society at least those are
questions of a kind that we settle
through a shared political process that
we set into motion through a
constitutional republic
how did blackrock come to be so dominant
how did they manage to
leverage the
to leverage themselves into a position
like this yes so it's a long story i
start to tell it in my in my first book
that there's two halves there's two
halves to the story one is the top down
cynical version that's the that's the
version i told in woke inc and that's
half the story the second of it relates
to our culture and the cultural and
generational moment we live in because
it takes two to tango consumers have to
fall for it what are the conditions that
allow consumers to fall for it that's
the subject of my most recent book
nation of victims which relates to our
culture of our general populace that
left our population vulnerable to the
trick but let me start with the first i
mean
on the on the realist side here the
top-down version of this
what happened was on the back of the
2008 financial crisis and by the way i i
lived this i got my first job in new
york city at a prominent hedge fund
on the eve of the 08 financial crisis i
i had somewhat of a front row seat to
this
what happened is that wall street and
financial institutions and big banks big
business more broadly but financial
institutions in particular went from
being the heroes of modern capitalism to
becoming the bad guys okay occupy wall
street was knocking on wall street's
doorstep the new version of the
barbarians were at the gate
and they were barricading they they were
they were barraging the gate okay
now there was a trick that came up right
around the same time that the occupy
wall street movement was saying you know
what we need to take money from those
wealthy corporate fat cats and
redistribute it to poor people to help
poor people
there was the birth of this new strand
on the left that started to say well
it wasn't quite just economic injustice
or just poverty that we need to address
it's also racial injustice and misogyny
and bigotry and climate change and the
racially disparate impact of climate
change that's actually the real problem
and that's when wall street woke up
where they said wait a minute this is an
opportunity this is an opportunity of a
generation to say that okay we can do
that
we'll talk about systemic racism if you
stop talking about systemic financial
risk we'll talk about
news about the racially disparate impact
of climate change after we fly in a
private jet to davos we'll do that all
day long but we expect that the new left
work with that old left and come to a
bargain where you agree to look the
other way and leave our game intact as
long as we use our game our power
corporate power included to advance some
of the agendas that you all love
so it was this cynical arranged marriage
between two bedfellows who didn't really
love each other it was closer to mutual
prostitution than an arranged marriage
but the net result was the birth of this
hybrid of state power and corporate
power that together was more powerful
than either one alone that was the
whether you want to call it the world
industrial complex the esg industrial
complex that was what through kerosene
just call it fascism you could call it
fascism yeah you could because that's
what fascism means fascism the union of
people out the tall
the merger of state power and corporate
power to advance but neither one could
alone this is a modern fascism no doubt
about it so so that was the birth of
that story top down but but as i said it
takes two to tango right i mean it takes
a culture to fall for this trick right
to not be able to see through it and so
what's going on there so that's that's
what nation of victims is all about it's
the spread of this new apologist
psychological attitude in our culture
that left an entire general population
that was vulnerable to be exploited by
this trick and at the end of the day
we also live in a moment where you know
my generation michelle your generation
our generation probably and younger
millennials gen z whatever
we're so hungry for a cause and purpose
and meaning and identity we're in the i
mean
probably not you and i personally as as
much i i know i'm not but on the
receiving end of of the largest
intergenerational wealth transfer in
human history and you know von mises
said this a century ago schumpeter said
it at points along the way
capitalism creates the psychological
need that anti-capitalism ultimately
fills and so this culture of accepting
this self-criticism those moral and
psychological insecurities in a
generation that's part of what allowed
the esg movement to make for good big
business good business over the last 10
years to aggregate funds to say that
you're going to invest not just for
return but also for virtue and the two
kind of
there's really three factors there i
mean one is defanging the occupy wall
street old left the second is a business
opportunity the third is a business
opportunity created by a generation of
consumers that were so psychologically
hungry for purpose and meaning and
identity and a cause that they fell for
it that together you got the the new
version of modern capitalism what was
supposed to be a challenge to the system
became the system and it's become i
think
the new form of fascist totalitarianism
effectuated ironically in the trojan
horse and in the veneer of the free
market itself which is actually pretty
frightening
interesting um how how much of this esg
these mandates um are contributing to
the energy crisis at the moment
a lot is the answer to that question
so so the number one sector
palpably damaged by the demands of the
esg movement is no doubt u.s energy at
western energy more broadly okay
and and
that's that there's reasonable debate
for that because is it the policy makers
that are responsible for is the esg
movement i think the answer is both but
i think the underappreciated role is the
role that the private actors themselves
display have played so
i actually sent a uh you guys may have
seen it i sent a public letter to the
board of chevron this week
as a shareholder of chevron right so my
new firm launched u.s energy fund
through that u.s energy fund as a
shareholder of chevron we sent a letter
to the boards
questioning certain of their behaviors
that it's a good case study but it's
just an example of a broader trend of a
company that did not want to adopt many
of these toxic measures how do we know
that we didn't want to adopt them
because when a scope 3 emissions
proposal and i can tell you what that
means but when a toxic scope 3 emissions
proposal was imposed by shareholders on
this company in 2021 the board of
directors said no
we recommend against this
it was proposed by a dutch non-profit
founded by a former refrigerator
salesman who wanted to fight climate
change who had
on the face of it no interest in
chevron's business success but put up a
shareholder proposal that 15 years ago
would have been appropriately ignored
but in 2021 earned the support of
blackrock state street and vanguard
giving it majority shareholder support
you shareholder and air quotes because
it's not their own money it's the money
of everyday citizens they're using to
vote in favor of it but at the end of
the day even though chevron's board said
no we don't want to adopt this we
recommend against it it earned majority
shareholder support with the aid of
folks like larry thinks blackrock state
street and vanguard
and and you know what does this kind of
proposal call for let me just be
specific about it it's it's a little
technical but it's important to
understand what a scope 3 proposal calls
for
it says an oil company like chevron
is responsible not just for reducing its
own emissions and not just reducing the
emissions resulting from its own use of
electricity and power in its own
business those are scope 1 and scope 2
respectively
but scope 3 emissions which means that
it has to reduce the emissions of its
employees in their commuting costs to
work carbon costs in their employee
business travel in their investments
that they make even in the use of their
fuel by every customer in their supply
chains so if you get this straight jesus
i mean this is staggering right so this
is how they reach the private sector the
private companies too because there's
many private companies in the supply
chain even though chevron's the public
company so i'm just gonna make this
really real for you okay here just to
make this crystal clear
this means that chevron
has to take responsibility for the
emissions
of a truck an amazon prime truck that
burns its fuel delivering food to
someone's home without demanding that
amazon make a reciprocal commitment in
return
that makes about as much business sense
as mcdonald's voluntarily committing to
reducing the body weight of everyone
who's ever consumed a big mac without
asking the consumer to bear any
responsibility in return so the question
i asked at the heart of the second
section of my letter to chevron this
week was why on earth is this possibly
in the best
business interests
of chevron this episode of the podcast
was sponsored by better fed beef a
cattle farming company that produces
extremely consistent and tender beef
it's really the only beef i eat now this
is the type of company that's going to
have major issues if esgs aren't
addressed
better fed produces high quality
certified anya beef from cattle raised
by local farming partners from the small
town midwestern united states the
stuff's as tender as american wagyu and
it's that tender but at a fraction of
the cost they flash freeze their meat
and ship their beef right to your home i
would and will never advertise a meat
company i don't fully believe in
so i even had my producer after last
episode who's on the carnivore diet say
okay but do you actually endorse these
guys
because i have a code mp for a massive
25 off your first order and i do it's
actually what i eat and it's the best
thing that i've found and i've tried
almost everything out there i can
basically eat and i'm thankful for this
i can basically eat whatever i want to
eat and this is what i choose to eat so
that's convenient they have an insane
number of options to choose from like
the backyard barbecue box tomahawk rib
eyes whole muscle ground beef skirt
steak ribs and a lot more even if you're
not on the lion diet or the carnivore
diet everyone can get healthier by
eating more beef and this stuff tastes
great you can also lose weight by eating
more meat which also helps you not fill
up on processed foods so it's a good
idea all around my listeners can take 25
off their first order by going to
betterfedbeef.com and using promo code
mp at checkout their website is
betterfedbeef.com their motto is real
beef from real families enjoy this
episode i hope you learned something
about esgs it's messed up and i think
that is the question at the heart of
this debate if it's in the right
interests of society great let's debate
it as a society through the democratic
process where everyone voice count and
votes counts equally but what you debate
in the boardroom of chevron or the
shareholders bring to the border of
chevron ought to be guided by a more
narrow question what is in the best long
run and this is to your second question
dr peterson yeah but your second
question what is in the long run best
interest of chevron that's the scope of
what ought to be debated in chevron's
boardroom
and and i think that there haven't been
other shareholder voices to the table
that's why i found it strive at the end
of the day we showed up as a shareholder
and and you know mike worth the ceo
responded to me the very day i sent the
letter you know he i was on cnbc he was
on bloomberg great let's have this
discussion out in the open
but michelle i think the positive part
of this just to you know end that rather
pessimistic answer with a small note of
optimism here
is that
the employees i've learned this pretty
quickly even in recent weeks i mean my
company we've engaged with over 10 u.s
energy companies already since we
launched our first fund that's a
shareholder of these companies
what i've learned is the employees of
u.s energy companies and even their ceos
and their boards
they're not the employees of twitter and
i mean that in a good way where elon
musk could buy twitter
he's going to have a lot of trouble
changing the behavior of 15 000 people
who don't want to do the thing he
actually wants them to do
in the u.s energy industry it's almost
the other way around where most of these
employees
are quietly waiting to run in this new
direction they just need to be liberated
from the handcuffs of the black rocks of
the world who are imposing these esg
mandates okay so what exactly is strive
doing to help liberate these
people bringing a different shareholder
voice to the boardroom
okay pretty simple so
so
just like blackrock and state street and
vanguard offer index funds that's what
strive is in the business of offering as
well expo ways for people to invest in
different segments of the market the
first tell people what an index fund is
so everybody's real clear about that and
what blackrock offers that's part of
what's part of my question about why
they be
they're in a position where they manage
so much money why would some what is an
index fund why would or should someone
purchase one and why yours say just out
of curiosity rather than say black rocks
yeah well we'll i'll get to the part
about strive in a second but actually is
a good point let's let's actually go
through a short history lesson of where
this index fund concept came from and
how it was that that resulted in
three institutions having 21 trillion
dollars of capital
it's a parallel to what happened in
social media which i think most people
understand better you have companies
that gave away their products for free
right you don't have to pay to use
facebook or twitter or whatever
instagram
but it's not actually free you only
realize that after the companies build a
network effect and realize that you know
you traded off a lot of other
contractual giveaways your access to
your data your privacy even what you see
on the internet well there was a similar
game that resulted in a network effect
in the asset management industry and
that was the rise of passive index funds
which said that you know what the old
school mutual funds which charged higher
fees to have portfolio managers that
were supposedly skilled at picking
individual stocks to outperform the
market
you know jack bogle the founder of
vanguard kind of said that you know what
that was bunk 99 of those people are
monkeys throwing darts on a board
they're not outperforming they're just
charging you a high fee for it
so what we'll invent is a new industry
that offers you really low fee exposure
to the market which isn't about
outperforming the market it's just about
owning the market but you get to own the
market for a much lower fee than
so-called actively managed funds like
mutual funds
right and there's no evidence there is
no evidence that actively managed funds
outperformed the market from what i
understand is that
the typical active fund manager
underperformed the market which means
they actually did worse than monkeys
throwing darts at a dartboard because
the monkeys didn't charge the fees right
well and also the monkeys were sampling
randomly
yeah i mean i think so so the i i'd say
the empirical data on this is is uh
cherry-picked around all sides but i
think i i'm very sympathetic to that
claim having looked at a lot of the
empirical data what they'll say in
response is yeah but if you take out the
really bad active managers then the ones
who really know what they're doing
actually outperform which is of course a
self-serving argument
but it's it's a rich empirical debate
but anyway i'm just given the
descriptive facts i think that jack
bogle made a compelling case to say that
you can't know who the good ones are or
the bad ones are in fact that may itself
be random so forget about it and just
use low fee exposure because even if
they're just monkeys throwing a dart at
the board and they're no better than
owning the market after you charge high
fees you might actually be worse off
than just owning the market at a low fee
so this was a convincing proposition i i
think it makes a lot of sense but what
happened was there was an invisible
trade-off the invisible trade-off was in
social media you know they're giving a
privacy what you see on the internet and
all that all those that good stuff
here the trade-off was they aggregated
not just the capital in providing
exposure to the market but they also
aggregated voting power to vote the
shares of those everyday individuals who
invest in the market now that may not be
a problem if they're just taking
financial considerations into account
into how they vote their shares but
starting in about 2018 and this was led
by blackrock it's worth remembering how
recent this really is in the voting
problem it's only started in about 2018
when larry fix said all right look
we can use this voting power to advance
certain social agendas and burnish my
own social standing and derive business
benefits from that by doing so
that's really when this story took a
dark turn
and the irony at the heart of this if
you think about that history lesson is
that the very people
who told you that
by admission we're too dumb to pick
stocks we're not smart enough to pick
stocks
yeah suddenly thought they were
sagacious enough to know how to design
an entire social universe
based on the social and environmental
mandates for how companies are supposed
to operate right so that that's a bit of
an irony if you think about it yeah yeah
you might say that right a bit of an
irony is that you can't pick single
stocks you can't determine
the probable course of the companies
that you hypothetically have expertise
in assessing but you can actually
pick with an unerring eye the direction
of the entire planet
environmental and the economy right
exactly so i don't want monkeys throwing
darts at a dartboard and picking stocks
but i definitely don't want those same
monkeys throwing darts at the design of
the social universe in western society
as we know it yet that's exactly what
happened because one became the vehicle
to aggregate the the capital to do the
latter so i've never really said it that
way but actually
you're
you're exactly right but more than more
than a bit of an irony
and and so so anyway that's the problem
so what am i doing i'm writing about the
problem i'm speaking about it i know as
a former ceo i've seen this from the
inside
at the end of the day though okay you're
only going to move the needle by shining
a spotlight on the problem okay i wrote
a book last year i'm writing this other
book that's coming out in a month and
that's more about the culture the
revival of excellence over these
apologist values okay we're going to
move the needle a little bit but how
about solving it so as i thought about i
i thought about maybe is this is this a
political problem that needs to be
solved through state action
agreed disillusioned by that path for a
range of reasons we can talk about but
then it became clear to me look if
there's a problem that originated in the
market
by golly let's solve it through the
market by actually bringing competition
to the table if this is an antique
competitive problem and and i can talk
for a long time if you guys are
interested in this about why i do think
it's an anti-competitive problem
well at the end of the day don't
complain about it solve it through
competition so that's what i did so i
founded strive
it's a new asset management firm
competing directly against blackrock
starting by also launching index funds
index funds that say we're just not
going to pick stocks we're just going to
offer exposure to the market
exposure to different sectors of the
market
but crucially bring a different voice
and vote to the table and the voice and
vote that strive brings to the table is
to mandate companies we're not asking
them we're mandating them as a
shareholder to focus exclusively on
delivering excellent products and
services to their customers
over any other agenda including social
or political agendas without regard to
larry finks or anyone else's social or
environmental or climate change or
racial equity goals
and and that actually closes the loop dr
peterson you said something interesting
about milton friedman you had a critique
of him which was he doesn't say anything
about the time horizon i agree with you
my other critique of milton friedman is
he doesn't say much about how it is a
corporate board is supposed to go about
this monumental task of maximizing
shareholder value that's irreducibly
vague in fact that's part of the
vagueness that allowed the esg movement
to then actually fill the void and say
no no we're actually concerned with long
run shareholder value
yeah what i want to do is make it really
clear and say focus on your products and
services for your customers that's how
you maximize your own value anyway
that's the voice that strives right so
you take responsibility for your
your particular level of interaction
with the actual market is that
people
who run a big company they have a domain
of responsibility it's not universal
perhaps they should be acting
universally in their private lives but
in their public and corporate life they
should be
doing the right thing by their customers
and then we'd hope that the aggregate
consequence of all the companies doing
right by their customers would be
everyone doing right in the broadest
possible sense
in the absence of a centralized control
system and the problem with the
centralized control system is you can't
predict the outcome rich which is
exactly as you pointed out what the
index fund managers were telling their
customers to begin with exactly exactly
so so in a certain sense this this
business opportunity should not have
existed i i never imagined i was going
to start another business again i
thought i was done with that but it was
staggering to me that the investment
firms that should have taken this on and
you know yeah i i don't mind i i'm
beyond the stage where i need to i need
to play delicately here so i'll just
tell you guys you know so so before i
started strive i had uh before i got you
know started in knowing what what the
next step entailed you know i was
meeting with asset management ceos
across the country and was curious
almost encouraging them this is a great
business opportunity you guys should
pursue in some sense my life would be
easier if somebody else was doing this
and i could you know go back to hanging
out with my family and writing books
but you know none of them wanted to do
it and so i actually actually uh met
with uh with the ceo of invesco i'll
just i don't mind let's just life's too
short not to just be transparent about
this stuff
it's a you know that's another trillion
dollar plus asset management firm
the ceo is uh is a guy who i'm told was
sympathetic to a lot of things that i
was saying in woke inc and elsewhere and
so so we had lunch when i was in town in
atlanta and and you know privately what
does he tell me okay well you know at
the end of the day i think it's fair
game let's just talk about this in the
open privately what does he tell me he
says he agrees with everything i'm
saying okay well that's that's
comforting except for the fact that when
you look publicly at the things he's
saying afterwards and even afterwards i
went to look at the public things he's
been saying
i promise you could not distinguish the
his quotes from larry fink's quotes
about the esg movement things like esg
is woven into everything we do esg is
the way of the future there is no
investment process without esgs stuff
like this coming out of his mouth very
similar to what larry fink has been
saying now his reason for why
is that large clients of his firm
would not
uh would not
allow him
to speak openly about his actual views
so in a certain sense pension funds like
calpers in the state of new york and
otherwise what they've done is they've
gone to these asset managers and say
that if you don't
adopt a firm wide commitment to the
climate action 100 network or to the
paris climate accords or to these esg
linked agendas then we're not going to
do business with you so what that
creates is is a is a difficult business
decision
for a new asset manager to make which is
to say that if i don't abide by these
agendas i'm going to lose business that
i have today yes there may be everyday
citizens out there who want me to do
something else but they're not the ones
exercising power in in my boardroom or
in my meetings
and so i'm just going to drag them along
for the ride because that's the most
profitable thing for me to do as a
business
well you know what the beautiful part
then about starting as a as a new
company is that you don't have those
legacy commitments and and by the way
from invesco to blackrock the biggest
constituent that they don't like to talk
about out loud is china those are their
some of their biggest growth
opportunities
is building asset management
subsidiaries in china and you will note
interestingly that as these companies
apply their esg mandates to western
companies like exxon and chevron they
don't say a pdp about esg to china and
that's not by accident
china wants them to be behaving that way
because that weakens the united states
and strengthens china by advantage
i kid you not petrochina is literally
picking up
some of the very projects that firms
like exxon and and
and chevron are dropping
and the irony of this is that you know
who own six percent of approximately
five or six percent of exxon is a firm
like black rock
you know who owns
five percent of petro china
so what do you think fink is up to
exactly i mean is this is there any of
this that's genuine or is it just like
unbelievably large-scale moral posturing
what what's go i mean look i feel i feel
some sympathy you know because i can
understand why people
would want to devote their
money towards hypothetically moral
ventures but i also understand that
devoting your time and money to a moral
venture is actually an unbelievably
difficult thing to do and if you think
you can
what would you call reduce your moral
venture to a handful of esg algorithms
you've got another thing coming and and
especially when you see what's happening
now too because i'm in europe at the
moment i'm in the uk okay which i guess
counts as europe and
they're facing a vicious winter and so
are the germans and the swiss announced
yesterday or the day before that they
would put people in prison for up to
three years if they turned their
thermostats above i can't remember if it
was 66 degrees 66 degrees three years in
jail and all of this is coming out of
this idiot esg
and it's subsidiary dei woke morality
and we're starting to put people in real
danger here so what do you think up to
exactly like what's going on here as far
as you're concerned well in spain
actually congress said it was less than
81 degrees fahrenheit is actually the uh
the legal threshold below which you
can't set your thermostat in the summer
in spain right
you know you know it's uh
you're right it's a difficult thing to
use your own money
to advance a moral agenda in your own
time and effort but the easier thing to
do
is just to use someone else's money to
do it instead so he has got to learn
things up to
that's why
what what why is he doing this do you
think he believes it
well he does believe why well it's so
leftist why in the world would larry
fink develop an uh an affinity for a
radical left policy well so there's two
things there's a few things going on
here i it may reflect his personal
politics i haven't met him yet uh so so
i can't speak to what his personal
politics are from what i hear that may
reflect some of his own you know
perspectives but but i think there's a
couple things going on here one is
a lot of these guys right i mean i was
in a room with jamie diamond couple
years ago i said same thing about him
actually a funny story with jamie
diamond at that dinner but i think this
stands for larry fink too he was asked
by someone else at the dinner you know
hey jamie you know you're spouting
you're saying all these great things
wouldn't you want to be president of the
united states ever
and he responded in candor it was it was
presented as a joke but it was so it was
funny not because it was false but
because it was true he said well
of course i would want to be president i
just wouldn't want to ever run for
president everyone in the world
because because oh yeah that's real
funny it was it was so it was funny not
because it was so obviously false but
because it's so obviously true so in a
certain sense for these guys it's about
exercising
political power right the the power
hungry version of impulse in each of us
as a human being you're able to exercise
that discharge that but without the
messiness of actually going through the
electoral process of the democratic
process that's messy why bother with
that when i can exercise and flex my
muscle
as a social actor through the private
sector itself so i think that's part of
the
story having a billion dollars isn't
enough
yeah yeah exactly you know exactly the
marginal utility of money goes down once
you have over it goes down every step
but definitely after you have over a
billion dollars an extra unit of dollars
or green pieces of paper matter less
than the ability to actually make your
mark on the world right so i think
that's a bit of what's going on here but
i think a bit of what's going on here is
also the economic incentives actually so
on the flip side
look blackrock has enjoyed a great
relationship with the us government
including with this current
administration who is staffed by many
alumni of blackrock who in return send a
lot of their business back through
blackrock and i think that if you want
proof of this
if you look at the asymmetry of how they
behave in china
and how they behave in the united states
both are tailored to how they gain
greater state favors in return in china
they gain straight state favors by
criticizing the united states and
applying esg in the us without applying
those same standards in china great
they'll roll out the red carpet
blackrock got to be the first foreign
owner of an asset management business
whole owner of an asset management
business in china that's a great
opportunity well you don't have to
believe me larry thinks says it himself
it's one of their big growth
opportunities
conversely in the united states you get
capital mandates from calpers in the
state of new york and and favorable
treatment from the presidential
administration that's in power so in a
certain sense the incentives are set up
for them to be able to do it now that
doesn't mean their clients benefit from
it because their clients money who's
being used to advance agendas that are
destroying the very industries that they
invest in in certain cases like the us
energy industry
but the people who run that money gain a
both economic and political advantage in
so doing so does that sound cynical yes
but but sometimes the truth requires
the the cynicism that it's important in
the real world it's impossible to be
cynical enough about the situation we're
in now where the entire energy market in
europe and in other places around the
world it's now starting to fall apart
for no other reason than that idiots
broke it
that's right that's right no doubt how
can you not be cynical about that
it's a crime not to be cynical about
that i agree i mean you have your head
in the sand and are contributing to the
problem indirectly if you don't actually
exhibit some agency in in seeing the
conspiracy that's hiding in plain sight
i mean i i now joke that esg in europe
stands for export soviet gas because
that's effectively the effect it's had
on on global energy markets at the end
of the day for every unit of oil or gas
production that's reduced in the united
states canada or norway which by the way
are three the cleanest places on the
planet to produce oil or gas in a global
market that's the slack is picked up by
russia and china and by the way
methane leakage is far worse from oil
production in places like russia or
china than it is in u.s the us canada or
norway and even if you buy into the
entire religion lock stock and barrel
methane is 80 times worse for global
climate change and global warming than
carbon dioxide yet somehow we
indulge the virtue that we're helping
the planet by shifting production to
places
like russia and china it's all about and
this is this is the problem oh and
and freezing and starving poor people
yeah oh yeah i mean i'm positional
benefit i'm just pointing out the
internal contradictions i mean there's a
whole
the whole the whole cost that it's
actually imposing on the rest of the
world
that we could go on for hours about that
but even on its own terms it's it's
debatable whether that's even achieving
the said decarbonization agenda because
methane is a form of carbon too that
even on the terms of the greatest
adherence to the climate religion is 80
times worse for global warming than
carbon dioxide so so and by the way you
know the cherry on top the biggest
opponents to fossil fuels in the esg
movement are also the biggest opponents
to nuclear energy which by the way is
supposedly the most carbon neutral form
of large-scale energy production known
to mankind vanguards esg funds
by rule
exclude nuclear energy companies which
show you what this debate is really
about to me
those two facts right the fact that
it really was it wasn't about reducing
carbon emissions so much as shifting
those same carbon emissions to the east
from the west
and then the second fact that actually
even as we're opposed to burning fossil
fuels we're also going to be opposed to
the utilization of nuclear energy
reveals something really important about
what's going on here and the thing it
reveals that is that this actually
wasn't about climate change at all this
wasn't about the energy debate at all
this was about an attack on human
flourishing particularly human
flourishing in the west relative to
other parts of the world and the problem
with nuclear energy for example
is that it might actually solve the
energy crisis even the clean energy
demand
too effectively and the problem is once
you've solved the problem
then you lose the trojan horse to pack
in all of the other social agendas
because wait a minute how are we doing
you also you also lose the opportunity
to exercise your unearned moral
superiority exactly god only knows you
don't want to give that up
exactly and this is as i say in my in my
books both of them the problem with
virtue signaling
is at some point
the appearance of virtue becomes more
important than being virtuous and that's
exactly what's happening here where
it's a form of dishonesty where there
were other agendas at work the global
equity agenda how else would the rest of
the world catch up with the west if it
weren't for asymmetrically imposing
fossil fuel caps on the west well that's
what explains the asymmetry and not
applying the esg standards to other
parts of the world it's also what
explains the opposition of the esg
movement to nuclear energy because both
of those could actually
solve the alleged
energy driven climate crisis
without actually accomplishing the other
social goals of addressing other global
injustices instead i'm not minimizing
that conversation but if we're going to
have that conversation let's have that
debate on the open in the open on its
own terms rather than using the trojan
horse of a climate religion to advance
that agenda instead and by the way
you're not even as we talked about even
helping that third world i mean at the
end of the day more eight times more
people today die of
cold temperatures rather than warm
temperatures and the best answers to all
temperature related deaths is more
plentiful and abundant access to global
energy you know whereas net zero yeah
okay
so at the end of the day they can be net
zero but they have bigger problems and
they're starving their people so so this
is uh so anyway i think there's so much
going on here but i think that you you
know we're very much on the same page on
this i would say dad can you talk this
is kind of off topic but can you talk a
little bit about what you told me a
couple weeks ago about ambassadors from
europe coming to canada and america to
ask for oh well it was it wasn't the
ambassador it was the chancellor of
germany who's a leftist
he came olaf shots came to canada cap in
hand about three weeks ago and said
to trudeau do you think you could open
up the lng pumps so to speak and canada
has massive uh uh reserves of of natural
gas and
natural gas is a very very clean energy
source high density clean energy source
i mean the americans started fracking
for natural gas in a big way
back around the turn of the millennium
and they cut their carbon output and
this is relevant to the next point about
what just exactly what are we trying to
accomplish here the death of western
civilization or saving the planet the
americans cut their carbon output by 15
by turning to fracking and canada could
have over the last decade invested
heavily in liquid natural gas production
and movement and then shipping we have
the uh technical ability to do it and to
do it cleanly and then we could have
provided europe with an alternative
energy source that was clean and
efficient they're going to turn back to
burning coal here right away they're
already doing that in germany
and anyways all of schatz who's one of
canada's great allies let's put let's
remember that came to
trudeau one of his fellow left-wingers
and said man we could sure use some gas
here since we're uh putin's surf and
slave because we set ourselves up to be
that and trudeau said
well
we don't think we can make a business
case for that and the reason he couldn't
make a business case for that is because
his bloody
appalling administration has done
everything they possibly could have to
make it absolutely impossible for energy
energy company to make a business case
for it because it's become so expensive
and so difficult to do business in
canada on the energy front that no one's
willing to risk the investment
you can't make this stuff up
you really can't
it's beyond comprehension this is at the
same prime minister who's who's spouting
off at every moment his um
ritual adherence to the support for the
brave people of ukraine but when it but
he's still willing to put all the power
in the hands of putin who is much more
masterful as far as i can tell at the
moment at the use of arbitrary power
than any of the opponents he faces in
the west
it means he's already put the screws to
europe and we just wait till the winter
comes if you think you've seen screws so
far man we ain't seen nothing yet right
you're so right about this i mean winter
is coming to europe no doubt about it
and and you know what putin's putin's
making a historical bet here i mean i i
i you know obviously i can't get in his
head but
you know if i if if you're putting
yourself in his shoes what are you going
to say russia has a long history of
outlasting its european opponents
through long cold winters look at
napoleon look at hitler they're not
going to be able to muster the political
power through this winter when they lack
enough energy to actually heat their
homes and you have to think about you
know it's not just trudeau i mean
you know you're you look at this from
the canadian perspective as a canadian
that's i think you're spot on i'll also
make a very similar observation as
american about president biden who with
one hand is giving 45 billion dollars in
aid to ukraine to fight against putin
on the other hand
the number one
lobby against the european ban on
russian oil imports was actually the u.s
white house who was actually president
biden which is in turn financing putin's
war machine that in turn allows him the
one thing that's gone well for russia of
course is oil and gas sales going up
since his invasion of ukraine so with
one end giving 45 billion to ukraine
with the other hand lobbying against a
policy that has the effect in turn of
increasing putin's cash machine to
finance his war machine so yeah well
let's not forget cozying up to the
iranians at the same point yeah of
course
because that's a fun little side effect
yeah
oh yeah
that's just yeah just a trivial and also
alienating the saudis at the same time
well he's doing that
so so it's if this is bad for if this is
bad economically
if this is bad geopolitically if it's
even as i made an argument before bad
environmentally on its own on the terms
of the environmentalist movement's own
terms
then
why is it happening
and at the end of the day it's that the
small handful of actors who have
benefited
both politically and economically
they wield so much aggregated capital
including capital aggregate from every
citizens across
western nations
they are actually the ones who are able
to influence all of these decisions
because they're self-interest that
sounds conspiratorial but it's hiding in
plain sight and this is not a left-wing
or right-wing debate as a consequence i
think this is a this is a 1776 issue
this is a question about whether you
believe in the distributed power both
distributed political power and
distributed market power that we set
into motion in 1776 the year of the
declaration of independence the year of
the wealth of nations both of those
people forget were both in 1776
is that what we believe
or do we believe in the old world
european model where a small group of
enlightened elites
decide the right answers to how society
is to organize its affairs
for the rest of society at large i mean
that's a legitimate debate it was a
historical debate we settled it in 1776
through a war we it reared its head
again in world war one that was that was
that was what was that issue in both
sides of the world war one
battle at the end of the day that has
now reared its head again in the 21st
century version of this and what's at
stake in the esg movement is the debate
between distributed power through a
democracy distributed power through
actual decentralized free market
capitalism
or the new version of monarchy and this
is not a left-wing actually agenda it is
a monarchical agenda
that i think people once they see what
it is hopefully it can debate this issue
in in terms of that's the sort of
partisanship that's the sort of thing
that russell brand keeps objecting to
because in some sense he's an objector
on the left and what he's fundamentally
objecting to is monarchical pretensions
on the part of gigantic
uh
uh corporations rather than gigantic
government actors but
a common enemy as you just pointed out
or a common threat i would say is
unconstrained gigantism period it
doesn't matter whether it's on the
corporate front or the government front
and remember back in 2008 the mantra was
too big to fail that's right okay how
about this for a mantra so big you must
certainly fail i like that actually yeah
i absolutely like that and well and it's
relevant to this issue of of uh
of the fundamental debate that you see
going on here is that
and it it's relevant to this issue of
so-called fascism that we talked about
earlier
too much centralized control constitutes
a catastrophe in and of itself it
doesn't matter if it's corporate or
governmental it's the same problem and
the problem is the tower of babel
problem essentially which is you have
one
centralized authority who has all the
responsibility and all the power and
everyone else is turned into a voiceless
peon and
that means the centralized authority
turns into a tyrant partly because they
get dissociated from the populace and
all of the intermediary structures of
responsibility that should be there as
an antidote to that
totalitarian structure are
are wiped out or demolished and
then you have the moral hazard that that
all accrues benefit at least in the
short term to the people who are
wielding the
the power and accruing the moral virtue
it's utterly appalling it is it is
appalling but i think that uh you know
i'm also just increasingly focused on
how it is we're going to do something
about this and i know this is something
that both of you think a lot about i i
think about it at the end of the day you
know you could think about breaking up
that distributed power i like breaking
that up through market competition it is
it is
wild to me it is staggering to me
that literally no one else has taken up
the mantle of creating an affirmative
alternative to esg i founded strive
earlier this year
okay i think others should be
ashamed of the fact that within the
first year strive is unambiguously the
world's
i think leading voice
offering an affirmative alternative to
esg in the marketplace how much can you
talk about how much capital you are
um
now
indirectly
responsible for and also what dangers
you think your approach might
produce you know because some of this
was unintended consequence of index
total development right so totally are
there dangers in what you're doing that
you see on the gigantism side and how
are you guys doing its drive well so so
there's there's i mean i have i i was
not without some reluctance that i
started strive because i i do worry
about
the bifurcation of a of an economy in a
democratic society i think the private
sector needs to be a place that provides
cohesion in an otherwise divided body
politic i mean this is tocqueville the
intermediating institutions american
capitalism is an a political
intermediate institution and so the last
thing and i'm very focused in the way
we're building strive to to minimize the
risk it is a risk but to minimize the
risk that we actually contribute to that
to that fracturing and the
politicization of the private sector by
affirmatively keeping our north star is
depoliticizing the private sector but
that won't be easy so strive is brand
new in its first fund only launched on
august 9th and the thing that was
staggering is within the first month
within the first three weeks we exceeded
300 million dollars in just that first
fund which makes it i think i'm told the
fastest uh launching
non-seated etf exchange traded fund of
the year
which for a newcomer you know it turned
a lot of heads in the in you could you
know look at the press around in the
financial price it turned a lot of heads
people were shocked what does that say
says and by the way the average uh trade
size in that first uh in that first few
weeks
was less than five thousand dollars so
the other funds that launched that
launched over 100 million dollars in the
first week the average trade size was
millions of dollars in our first week it
was less than five thousand dollars in
our first three weeks i think we had
over 400 000 visits to our website i
mean i read many of these messages were
flooded by them so this is a bottom-up
demand of the everyday citizen who
understands
their their their money and their voices
being exploited by someone else today
i think that there's a potential title
wave of everyday citizens who are hungry
for a different alternative but the
system is so set up in an intermediate
way that that it's going to take a new
market actor and that's not easy that's
the mountain we're climbing taking a
jackhammer to that system to ultimately
break the dam to actually allow the
voice of the everyday citizen to be
heard over all of the intermediating
financial institutions that actually
serve as gatekeepers to advancing the
voice and the interests of the ultimate
capital owners the everyday citizen
whose money is being invested now
i think that i think that part of this
you know i'm solving this aiming to
solve this i hope through the market i
hope to god there are other competitors
like strive to step up to the plate and
i think that will help solve the problem
that i worry about which is that there's
one unilateral institution that
represents this other alternative
viewpoint to the otherwise codified esg
hegemony i don't want hegemony in any
direction i want a diversity of
viewpoints represented in a marketplace
of ideas and representing the
marketplace of capital and products
that's distributed so i don't want
strive to ever become a 20 trillion
dollar financial institution i think we
should by that point have greater
competition in the marketplace of
capital and products and ideas that
keeps the flow of capital competitive
for the everyday citizens who are
participants in that economy and and so
do i worry a little bit about that
that's a high-class problem as a
business that we'll turn to in the in
the future but i i worry in the meantime
about also politicizing this whole
debate which is unfortunately what the
esg movement has done but even when you
counter it through a movement of
depoliticization it's hard not to be
seen
as a as a politicized effort in its own
right so that's what makes this a
uniquely challenging thing to really do
right
not just to go to the lowest hanging
fruit and say that well we're going to
create the conservative version of the
liberal esg movement i think that would
be the wrong way to do this
versus to say that the way we want to do
this is to actually take a
de-politicized approach that focuses
exclusively on what companies should be
doing and to take those political
questions as important as they may be
and to have the humility to say that we
don't deal with those questions those
should be reserved to the political
process
and that was part of why i wrote the
book as well so i mean we're i'm
releasing the book you know this week
right and at the end of the day
part of the book what i hope to achieve
through the book is
it's going to take a citizenry who
is no longer susceptible or vulnerable
to the demands and to the to the siren
song of the virtue signaling and the
advertising through virtue that has
empowered the esg movement
and what i worry about is that we can
live in this moment where we have this
black hole of identity in an entire
generation an entire nation and an
entire western civilization
that the kinds of things that used to
fill those moral voids whatever they may
have been right you mean like family
family that was at the top
family as an example and we we could we
could have other examples hard work as
an idea people used to derive identity
from hard work
religious patriotism
yeah community all these all these
subsidiary organizations levels of
social organization
i mean in in some ways you're you're
you're going to intuit this even more
deeply than i did in writing this book
just because it's where you spend your
your you know waking hours over decades
of scholarship but but you're right
about that whatever those may have been
that filled those void that void of
identity and meaning and purpose when
we've lost that there's this black hole
of a vacuum yeah that then allows poison
to fill the void and so one of my goals
with nation of victims was
look
far be it for me to have all the answers
but at least to start the conversation
about offering one vision of what it
means from an american context what does
it mean to be an american in 2022 if you
ask most of america's citizenry i don't
believe they have a good answer to that
question
i offer one answer to that question
which is part of what it means to be an
american includes the reason why many
immigrants including my parents travel
across the world to be part of america
is to pursue excellence unapologetically
to say that the shared pursuit of
excellence of self-actualization and to
be free to do so in whatever way we as
individuals and free agents determine is
the right way for us to pursue
excellence in our lives to be able to do
that to be able to do it in an
unrestricted way and to be able to do it
unapologetically that is part of what it
means to be american well i wanted i
would i would put a twist on that so i i
just did a seminar in miami on the
biblical story exodus
and exodus is the prime story that uh
that
let's say people promoting freedom of
all political stripes referred to when
trying to foment
transformation in the face of tyranny
and one of the things that god says to
moses when he's enjoining moses to push
back against the tyranny of the pharaoh
is
let my people go and that's that call to
the sort of freedom that you just
described but that's actually not what
god says and
it's said ten times one for each plague
he says let my people go
so that they may serve me in the
wilderness
and so it isn't freedom exactly it's
constrained freedom and the reason i'm
making this case is because the case you
just made there for freedom versus say
top down tyranny can turn into kind of
an atomistic protestant liberalism where
we're nothing but atomistic actors
defining our identities subjectively
it's sort of and so here's an
alternative vision of freedom it's like
well you're free free to
vary and play as an individual but
that's within a relationship within a
committed long-term relationship because
that puts some boundaries on you and
then
to devoted towards families and then
devoted towards communities and then
devoted towards states and nations and
then may be devoted to the international
order and you have to have fealty at all
of those levels and that actually
constitutes your identity
right so not just the freedom i agree
with you wholeheartedly and so you
responded to the to the
appropriately to the way i framed it in
that uh in that 22nd rant in summary of
the book but but in actuality
you know one of the arguments i also
make and this is synchronous with what
you just said is that actually actually
virtue
is not a product of capitalism actually
i think the virtue is a precondition for
capitalism to deliver on its promise
right and so i'll give you an example
and i laid this out and uh now i'm
losing track with which book it came up
in but
across the two books you know facebook
actually faced a lot of criticism i've
been a public critic of a lot of the
censorship on social media so people
called me when facebook faced criticism
for its knowledge
that teen girls using instagram suffered
body image issues that were caused by
the platform and that it's anger
management that people suffered anger
issues when using its platform and they
knew about it and they didn't do
anything about it and they expected me
to criticize facebook since i had
criticized facebook for censorship
practices but my response is actually
different
i actually said that you know what
i'm not sure i want facebook in fact i'm
sure i don't want mark zuckerberg in
charge of being responsible for
cultivating the kind of self-confidence
and identity and virtue in a teen girl
that gives her
the psychic security and fortitude to
not be vulnerable to being picked out by
an algorithm in the way that that
instagram works in fact i think that's
part of the problem is that again
we didn't cultivate enough of that
psychic fortitude that virtue whatever
you want to call it in the offline world
that left them vulnerable to being
algorithmically exploited in the online
world but the answer
isn't to make mark zuckerberg or jack
dorsey a modern rabbi or a modern-day
priest it's to actually do the hard work
in the offline world even outside the
sphere of the market to get to the same
place and so one of the cases i make in
the nation of victims and and i don't
know if a lot of conservatives are going
to love this dr peterson i'm going to be
really honest with you i i don't know
much care
i think that there's there's there's two
components to this and i'm speaking from
an american context american identity
part of it is responsive to the half of
us
that the half of us internally i mean
half of me internally that wants to be
the individualist the rugged
individualist pursuing my own dream as a
free agent expressed through free market
capitalism okay that's half of the story
the individualist
but if we're being honest with ourselves
each of us as citizens also hungers to
be part of something that is greater
than ourselves a whole that is greater
than the sum of its parts and that too
is part of what it means in the american
context to be an american and in that is
is i think
the beautiful tension at the heart of
western identity at the heart of
american identity the individual the
whole
you know individualism and unity it's
they sometimes run roughshod over one
another capitalism and democracy i think
are the expressions of each of those and
one of the things that i think the
conservative movement gets wrong so i
would want to be the last person that
was that was guilty of committing the
same mistake was talking
disproportionately about the former
which is just the pursuit of freedom
through the system of free market
capitalism something that we've lost and
need to revive no doubt
but without talking about the revival of
a bad word i'm going to use here but
it's a word i think we need to at least
we at least need to talk about more the
revival of
civic duty
to a nation that also is part of what it
means to be a citizen and i think that
the two actually go hand in hand because
part of the stakeholder
siren song is to be the apologist for
being the capitalist pursuing your own
self-interest but that comes from the
fact that you never were actually a
fully formed citizen who had lived out
his civic duty in the first place so you
have the psychic insecurity that gave
you the muscle memory of neither
pursuing self-interest nor pursuing
sacrifice ever properly because the two
are always co-mingled and what i think
is we actually need to revive the muscle
memory of doing each of those things
unapologetically in our different
capacities as both capitalists and as
citizens by separating those activities
and those pursuits from one another and
a lot of the things i think the
conservative movement particularly the
united states gets wrong is it's
completely sacrificed and given up on
this idea of civic duty as a constituent
feature of citizenship itself and the
idea of being a citizen of a nation is
part and parcel of what gives you the
foundation to then
be a self-interested capitalist in the
sphere of the market and part of what
allows capitalism to then fulfill its
promise in an otherwise democratic
society which is to say that you know i
often joke that but it's not really a
joke but i do joke saying that
everything that's ever wrong with
capitalism could be explained by the
fact that our wants do not fully match
our needs and that divergence and the
delta between the two is what we might
call virtue in the first place which is
why i come back to what i started with
which is virtues of precondition for
capitalism to deliver on its promise so
so i i don't know how much of that you
resonates with you or or you agree or
not but but uh that's definitely a big
part of the book
well i think i'll add one thing to that
and then i'll turn the questions over to
michaela again um
look if you're not a virtuous citizen
and you're a capitalist
like a self-interested hedonistic
capitalist free-market
uh individualist
you're going to be guilty because you're
not oriented in the proper direction
let's say towards the highest of all
things and the problem with being guilty
is that when the mob comes for you and
accuses you you're going to be guilty
and then you're going to do foolish
things like abide by esg statutes let's
say and try to backpedal because you're
guilty for what you've done and it is
exactly as you said because the sacred
duties of citizenship and the identity
that goes along with that which is
actually psychologically protective in
the highest degree that's been
sacrificed and part of what's happened
too is now that's being replaced by this
insistence that only subjectivity
defines identity which is an
unbelievably immature and pathological
insistence
and so
that fractionates and alienates everyone
on the basis of their subjectivity and
that also facilitates the transfer of
responsibility and power to the people
at the top of the towers of babel
so revitalization of citizenship in its
broadest sense that's a that's
absolutely necessary and this is one of
my failures in woking it's what it was
one of my regrets in that last book is
is that i didn't
i didn't do anything with this idea of
citizenship and that was the gaping hole
that led me to write this this new book
so that's at the heart of nation of
victims actually and
there's a chapter in the book called a
theory of duty it plays on the john
rawls trope of a theory of justice
i think that uh you know david hume had
a famous thought experiment about the
missing shade of blue he believed that
he could infer
from a spectrum of shades of blue
a shade of blue that was missing from
that he could tell you exactly how it
looked without ever having seen it but
it's what he called his missing shade of
blue i call this the missing shade of
red for the american conservative
movement is this theory of duty and so
if i had to pick up a chapter of the
book that was the most important it was
the chapter entitled the theory of duty
and and i think that that was that was
part of what i missed in even what was
in retrospect a more myopic perspective
that i brought to bear in woke inc that
i hope at least
you know begins the project of filling
out that vacuum in nation of victims
you guys are talking about
revitalization of citizenship but what
are examples of civic duties people
should actually pursue
so i i shall i start with that please
please yeah okay well
you i think you can think about it
hierarchically and and that's the most
effective way to do it you you owe
your yourself
your extended self you owe a duty which
means you you have to act in a manner in
the present that doesn't sacrifice your
medium to long-term viability and
well-being and i think the voice of
conscience
and the voice of meaning are pointers to
that and so when your conscience calls
you on your misbehavior it's because
you're subordinating
your long-term sustainability and growth
to the hedonistic and impulsive demands
of the present
and so you're acting in a very immature
way you're not making the proper
sacrifices even in
relation to yourself and then you have
to have someone along for the ride
someone that you commit to
over the long run a wife or a husband
who you bind yourself together with and
struggle through life with and then
that's a foundation for a family
and that family the children in your
family they remind you i just watched
bill burr's news special it was quite
funny very politically incorrect and
bill burr has a real temper and he
doesn't control it well by his own
admission and he says his his two and a
half to four-year-old daughter so over a
two-year span has been a
signal
um what would you call it
moderator of his temper because when he
gets upset his daughter has learned to
come and pat him on the shoulder and
tell him that he's going off the handle
and that he should be careful and that
he doesn't have to be so upset and
your children do modify you if you set
the circumstance upright to keep the
harmonious balance
of life going in your family you have to
modify your own stupidity and that keeps
you sane
and then you do that with your family in
relationship to your local community and
then the state and the province and then
the national
sphere and the business sphere and the
sphere of your friends and then you can
think of mental health not as something
that's subjectively defined or even
subjectively experienced but as the felt
sense
of the harmonious balance between all
these different levels of identity
stemming from you all the way out to
well to the broadest possible sphere and
that is as the vect pointed out that's
something conservatives haven't figured
out is that you can sell to young people
and i've seen this in my lectures you
can sell people young people the idea of
multi-dimensional social identity and
responsibility as a solution to their
problems of nihilism and meaninglessness
and it's the genuine solution it's not
an ideology or a
a band-aid solution it's like that's
life
to do all those things at once properly
and and that is uh
it is it's a gaping hole in our culture
that that isn't being filled by much at
the moment
okay so would that be summed up in
like actual actionable things people can
do would that be summed up and figure
out how to have a proper relationship
and get married and ideally have kids
well that's a start with
yeah well that's your job you have your
friends you have your civic duty as the
vic points out join a political party
join a church don't your cynicism about
those things especially when you're
young doesn't justify your lack of
participation of course they're corrupt
and blind partly because no young people
are in there
working diligently to set them right now
i mean young people have things to learn
too but they can at least be eyes for
the blind
so
i i i
um i'm going to throw something out here
and and i'm going to say that this is
something that i'm not um i'm not there
on being fully committed to yet but i am
i'm i'm a lot closer than i would have
been 10 years ago i have to admit that
or even five years ago even two years
ago
mandatory military service
mandatory military service i struggle
with that because of the aggregation of
state power and what that means but the
cultivation of citizenship and co-equal
citizenship
is something that cannot be
simply wished upon a society it has to
as your capacity as a citizen
has to be earned and what i what i
believe is if we see ourselves as truly
co-equal citizens
then we will stop obsessing over
fetishizing the differences in the green
pieces of paper or whatever other
petty privileges are the superficial
privileges that now we obsess over over
correcting for and those native
psychological impulses i think are are
rendered
silly by comparison to a deeper civic
equality and i think many conservatives
will cringe at this idea i would have
cringed at this idea as recently as a
few years ago but i think that actually
that's part of our path
to the shared revival of excellence and
individual self-actualization is the
insecurities that stop us and shackle us
from being able to pursue our own vision
of excellence and self-actualization as
free agents in the world
are in part created by the psychological
apologism the i forget the word used
with the guilt right that was created by
the lack of civic equality in the first
place there may be some very pragmatic
benefits to this in the west anyway i
mean we can talk about the rising and i
think potentially inevitable the city's
trap-esque uh you know destiny that i
think we in in the united states and
canada alike may face with the rise of
china and you know i think triggered by
the invasion of taiwan which i think is
upon us in the next couple of years and
the implications for the global
semiconductor supply chain to the way we
even live our western lifestyle very
much at stake for what happens there in
in a realist in
in a realist sense of the world this may
not be an option anyway but but
putting aside what for this conversation
i'll call just a positive externality
i'm actually solving for a different
internal goal of
reviving the psychic and civic fortitude
of an entire nation
in a certain sense those aren't two
different issues anyway i think that our
foreign policy and our ability to
project strength abroad starts with our
civic strength at home but brings me
back to an idea that i would not have
even entertained as one that made it to
the table of conversation two years ago
to some that i'm actually quite growing
increasingly sympathetic to in the
american context maybe in the canadian
context of of uh like in an israeli
sense of the in an israeli sense of the
model
a mandatory civic service through
military doesn't have to be combative
military but but in some sense of
actually serving the national security
of the united states or canada of being
a citizen of a nation state
like it is to be a citizen of israel
today part of what it entails is is
acting out that civic duty over a one or
two year period or period that's
distributed over the course of a decade
that's the implementation question but
the idea itself i'd really be curious
for your reaction to that because well
i'd be well i'd be inclined to
make that an invitation rather than a
necessity and that that i think the
right way to do that perhaps
is to do the sort of thing that we're
doing in this conversation which is to
make a case
that without
pronounced civic engagement and the
sacrifice of a narrow hedonism that that
necessitates we're all going to be not
only in trouble socially but we're also
going to be in trouble individually
that you have to pick something above
yourself to serve or you'll be miserable
and unhappy and yet but but i think to
the degree that you do that voluntarily
that because voluntary participation is
so important psychologically as well and
i think you can do that by telling
people
the right compelling story
and people so you're optimistic that's
an optimistic view that's an optimistic
well it is it isn't it's not that easy
to formulate the story properly right
that's the trick and yeah one of the
things i have learned on my lecture tour
um hundreds of times now i would say is
that
it's possible to make a case for the
redeeming quality of responsibility and
maturity
it's possible to make a case that people
really respond to if you can do it
clearly and lucidly enough and to say to
people look
you might think of these external
games these external constraints as
nothing but restraints on your
hedonistic freedom why should i get
married you know when i could have my
choice of women it's like
well
marriage in some sense is a constraint
but in another sense it's a game
and a protective container and a
precondition for your life
and you do give something up by deciding
to play one game rather than another
let's say but you do not nearly as much
as you give up by not being able or
willing to play any games whatsoever
can i stay on that analogy for a second
because i think it's so interesting to
the national case which we'll come back
to right after that but
so so then then we get into an
interesting discussion about
do you think that let's take the eastern
model
you know my family's context historical
context of my parents for example in
india or whatever
achieving that benefit but but somewhat
through mandate right is the arranged
marriage model and certainly my
grandparents generation the arranged
marriage model that you didn't really
have a choice but but you the society
was set up
to give you that
binding constraint but not even one that
you volunteered into my model of it was
actually volunteering into the same
model in the life that i live
how much of the benefit you derive from
that constraint the psychic
vacuum that it fills
is the choice that you make into being
bound versus how much of it is just from
the experience
of actually having it be so look that's
a really good that's a really good
question um
one of the things we do know
psychophysiologically let's say is that
if you present people with a stressor of
a certain magnitude so imagine it's a
an occurrence that would require a
certain amount of time and energy and
resources to overcome
if you present them with that stressor
arbitrarily you have to do this or you
bring them on board so they can choose
to do it voluntarily the pattern of
psychophysiological response is
completely different
in the first situation it's a stress
response and it tends to be
physiologically damaging especially if
it's exceptional
in the second case it tends to be
beneficial and so i would say an
optimized social accord
is predicated on voluntary agreement
now you might say well it's impossible
always to negotiate towards an optimized
solution and i would say well that seems
to be the case with criminals for
example and so maybe there are
circumstances under which compulsion is
required but you know
part of what we're arguing against here
on the esg front in some sense is is
compulsion yeah well is to remove that
compulsion yeah and and so i think and
you're offering people with strive
you're offering the opportunity to
choose a different path and you have a
powerful narrative associated with that
and i would say that's optimal
if you can do it now that doesn't make
it easy
yeah i would identify a third space
actually
the way i'm thinking i'm still thinking
about this in the analogy between
marriage and the
you know the eastern arranged marriage
context versus the western chosen
marriage model
and its implications for the national
service and the military service uh
discussion we were just having
but i i wonder if there's a third a
space for a third
category right you talked about the the
model of of
sort of forced
forced adoption of behavior versus
choice and and the benefits even psychic
benefits associated with psychological
benefits associated with
um you know actually choice being an
important component to it
i wonder about a third space and this is
actually closer to the arranged marriage
model right no one was using police
force or back government backstop
military force to say dug on it you two
are going to marry each other but it was
woven into the social fabric so much so
as to become the norm
right this this is this is the societal
norm and expectation
that this is how this is the binding
constraint that you will adopt not
having choice of women but
be bound to this household and to derive
that benefit not backstop by by the
police state at gunpoint
but there is there's an element of it
that's different than just voluntarily
being persuaded by the arguments either
well well look one of the things you
really look man people want norms let's
look at the situation with teenagers yep
we think of teenagers as rebellious well
they're not rebellious they're so peer
oriented it's beyond comprehension
well they're rebellious against their
parents because they're trying to move
away from dependence into the broader
world but they're starving for norms and
every teenager is dying to fit in and i
mean that literally if you don't fit in
you're going to want to die as a
teenager it is no joke and so
the notion that there should be norms
and ideals to for people to follow that
are part and parcel of the cultural
structure is actually the definition of
a cultural structure and i think it is a
third way between well it's it's
tradition versus force
you might say well tradition you're
maybe you're a faller of jean-jacques
rousseau and you say well people are
naturally good
except insofar as society warps them
it's like
well
that's half the story
society can warp you to some degree but
it also shapes and molds and guides you
and provides you with necessary the
necessary rules of playable games
and and that's not well explained to
young people anymore at all that really
what they don't want absolute freedom
they want the freedom to choose a game
and then abide by the rules of the game
and tradition offers them a variety of
time tested
and sustainable games
dad
going back to
you talking about how you have to
basically choose your hardship otherwise
it's traumatizing right you can't be
forced into it um is there any
literature talking about whether or not
something that is maybe a little bit
harder than you would choose would still
be maybe even more beneficial to you
like i know some of the hardships i've
been through that i would have avoided
at the time i look back on and think oh
no i wouldn't go back and change it but
at the time there's no way in hell i
would have chosen that route yeah yeah
yeah not that you want that implemented
by the government we're talking about
optimality here you know um your your
mother and i were talking about
relationships the other night uh
in response to some dancing we've been
doing we've been experimenting with this
new dance that where we push on each
other's hands and play
right and and it's quite interesting
because you can balance against each
other extremely precisely and so it's
very interesting way of dancing i
learned it from a woman in nashville
when i was down there
she volunteered to give me a dance
lesson in any case part of what you're
doing in a relationship is providing
each other with optimal resistance
right and you do that in a competition
in the game as well you you want to be
playing against someone who's about as
good as you
and then that pushes you to the limit
and i would say michaela that the marker
for being pushed to the optimal limit
is that you're playing intensely and
then if it exceeds that then it starts
to get risky now you might say well
that's not as risky as never being
challenged and i think that's true
because never being challenged is the
pathology of hyper dependence
but if you exceed your limits and it
starts to become not fun
part of that's a marker that you're
exceeding your psychophysiological
capacity to
master the new challenge at the rate at
which it's occurring
now you still might be able to do that
but you know generally if someone goes
through a period of time that's
extremely difficult
then it takes them quite a long time to
recover now they might be better off
afterwards but it's still they still pay
a price for it if it's
the right
the resistance what was the word you
used there i really liked it you said it
was it was
optimal resistance optimal resistance
yeah so optical though you know
the word help meet which is what god
calls eve when he makes her for adam
means in the hebrew it means beneficial
adversary
it means a partner yeah it means partner
of optimal resistance and that's
actually a play partner because a play
partner is
a adversary of optimal resistance
that's like a definition of what
constitutes play
and so i would say i'm trying to work
this out too trying to solve some of the
problems that you're addressing is like
what's the antithesis of power and
compulsion
like specifically what's the antithesis
and the antithesis to the spirit of
power and compulsion is the spirit of
play
yeah and we know that in the animal
animal literature as well and it's not
freedom without that resistance which is
exactly the whole the libertarian siren
song so yeah this is also not freedom
it's also not freedom without structure
because if you're going to play
it's going to be a game the structure's
part of what provides the optimal
resistance right that's what that's
that's what introduces the play and so
so i love this analogy it really speaks
to me you know in in sort of my marriage
you know that that i think describes how
why why we work
but well vivek it's not it's not that
the rules are the optimal resistance the
rules provide the precondition for the
joint engagement in optimal resistance
conditions okay for play yeah yeah yeah
well right because if you're both
playing basketball you can hone your
basketball skills totally totally
absolutely okay so so what i'm
interested in is is
how
can we or if at all should we
extend that to the relationship between
citizens in in a co-equal relationship
with one another and the role of the
nation-state or even the relationship
between the citizen
and the and the nation well you know
there's there's a biblical injunction
right that you can't enter the kingdom
of heaven until you become like little
children
and that's a very peculiar injunction
but a huge part of what that means and
this isn't all it means but a huge part
of what that means is that
if you're an optimized adult you
rediscover the spirit of play in
everything you do
and then you invite people along for the
game you know that as a businessman to
the degree that you've been a successful
businessman you tell me if this is wrong
if you're selling to someone you don't
force or pressure them into it what you
do is you go say look here's a bunch of
things i'm doing and i think they have
value and there are some things you
doing that seem to have value and we
could jointly
bring our
uh our abilities together and we could
do something even better and and then
they say i'd be thrilled to do that and
then your interests are aligned and away
you go and you know cynics will say that
isn't how business works and i would say
well you go try to run a successful
business and you'll find out pretty damn
soon that that's how it works when it's
working yeah no doubt about it no i will
i will second that right away
um
but but but what is that what are the
implications of that for the nation
state discussion though
well i think you build that spirit of
play everywhere that you can around you
you know and you practice that with your
wife and you practice that with your
kids and then
maybe you know part of what we're doing
in this conversation
is playing
right we're here by our own voluntary
uh will and
you have some things to say and michaela
has some things to say and we're pushing
back and forth to see if we can optimize
our conceptions
and
we want to be doing that all the time
everywhere with everything we do
now that's a very hard thing to manage
especially if you're trying to deal with
people who don't know how to play
you know and criminals might be the most
classic example of that many criminals
and this is straight from the clinical
literature
of a very large proportion of career
criminals
are kids who did not learn to play
properly between the ages of two and
four
it's a well-documented clinical
literature
so then they can't play and they don't
know how to play with others so they
enforce their
their their narrow
and selfish hedonistic and impulsive
games on others using compulsion
and then they're not popular no one
wants to be around them then they get
resentful and bitter and that makes them
even more criminal
it's a cat it's a catastrophe they don't
know how to play
so
and some people are much harder to play
with than others and that's a you know
common problem but still that's still
what we should be aiming for
do you think um
do you think as a country or as a people
that are kind of bound together
people need to have some sort of common
enemy
which
it's kind of a side note to the whole
playing thing but i mean um we seem to
as a society be saying okay the common
enemy maybe right now or racists or it's
climate change but you were talking
about how people should potentially have
mandatory
you know being very mandatory
that's what satan is for
yeah but that might be a little bit
too uh
that's kind of difficult to operate to
comprehend for a lot of people well well
yeah that's partly because we lack a
reasonable religious education but the
idea yeah yeah clearly the case that
people can unite against a common enemy
the problem is you get the enemy wrong
yeah then you demonize the wrong people
or you demonize people period the
the the judeo-christian presumption
let's say is that you identify that
enemy in your own heart and you try to
constrain it there
and then and then that does motivate you
right because it is motivating to work
against what's terrible as well as to
work towards what's good
but if you locate it inside
then you don't end up
with pitchforks and and and torches you
know mobbing yeah well that's the that's
the plan
that's cool
the the difficult question is
how to
how to
actualize this vision amongst
a populace that
you know maybe through no fault of their
own as individuals but because of the
structures we've created
has very little interest or or ability
to
engage in that type of play with i think
look i think the interest is there look
you know what look what's happening with
your company you said most of the people
who are investing are small investors
that's right so you've offered them a
better game i wouldn't underestimate the
hunger for this at all i mean i see it
all the time as i'm touring the reason
yeah i think the hunger is deep as long
as people are able to recognize it and
show up yeah oh yeah well it's not easy
for people to articulate these sorts of
things and they don't they don't
they have the hunger and they and
there's a desire say to adopt
responsibility that's definitely true
but the
narrat the coherent of the coherent
narrative
that would entice them towards doing
that voluntarily in the absence of
social norms has been lacking because we
haven't been conscious enough to
formulate it but certainly in your books
you're trying to formulate it you're
trying to absolutely consciously and you
decided to take it upon yourself to
produce this company and you're allow
and this is a game it's
it's a game it's like would you want to
support esg with your money or do you
want to wake up and see what's going on
and try this alternative route
and so that's what you're doing and and
it looks to me like you're doing it in a
very positive manner so even in your
books you're you know your books are
diagnostic
but they're not demonizing not you know
you try to point out where the problems
might be but you're not trying to foist
it off on someone else and you are
making a very strong case in what you're
doing
i would say in your writing but also on
the business front for the adoption of
something like
localized
non
of babel
adoption of responsibility financially
and ethically and and
that's a marketable story man yeah in
the highest sense
well thank you for saying that i mean
that's what i i'm hopeful that that will
that that will get us there or at least
get us enough it's the only thing it's
the only thing that could get us there
that doesn't mean it will because the
alternatives are something like tyranny
and slate the alternative to play is
tyranny and slavery mm-hmm that's the
old freezing freezing major well
freezing in the dark yeah yeah yeah
okay uh vivek
what could like the average person who's
listening do to try and go against
these esgs what can they do with strive
yeah i mean look i think that uh at a
higher level putting strive even to one
side i can come back to that
look when you feel like you're the only
person
who's in a room whatever that room may
be
who believes what you do
i think you have a civic obligation to
speak up and express yourself and i
think what you'll find
is that when you do it you probably
weren't the only person in that room who
believed what you did and so what is
strive doing it strives as providing a
vehicle
for people to be able to speak but
without having to take the same level of
risk that they might
by doing that at a meeting at work or at
a board meeting or at a place where they
may actually take risk of putting food
on the dinner table one of the beauties
of buying an exchange traded fund on the
new york stock exchange is that it's
anonymous but you're able to speak at
the end of the day with the dollars you
invest you're actually speaking to
corporate management teams to boards
as an owner telling them how you would
like to see them behave yeah you you've
also put your money where your mouth is
exactly real moral virtue in that that's
not virtue signaling that's a bet that's
a sacrifice of value it's the real thing
and so it's the real thing i love about
what you're doing in speaking and and dr
peterson i think the one thing that
struck me is this is from the stories
who of people who have
you know even recent weeks come out of
the woodworks and really shared their
experience of why they're drawn to this
is that
if they said that
at work
they may not
be able to have certainty they're going
to get that promotion or even keep their
job or put food on the dinner table
but to be able to say it and to fully
express themselves with their
hard-earned dollars and hard-earned
investment dollars and savings to be
able to say that you know what i'm going
to unapologetically express myself
that's it that that's an intermediate
way of being able to speak that
hopefully gets people in our culture and
our cultural norms to a place where they
don't just have to do it through
anonymous
uh capital investment where you know
thankfully i don't have to worry about
putting food on the dinner table so i'm
speaking on behalf of everyone who puts
their money into strive or strives funds
great but gets us culturally to a place
where we won't need that anonymized
intermediary vehicle either we're able
to do it in other spheres of our lives
as well by normalizing it right to think
about the
use of norms and the way in which strive
i hope what we're doing is then changing
norms and so what can the everyday
citizen do well look part of the point
of launching exchange traded funds is
that those are democratized those are
accessible to everyday citizens unlike
hedge funds or private equity vehicles
that because of i think misguided laws
limit the the accessibility of that to
the everyday citizen part of the reason
i didn't want to just start some sort of
alternative hedge fund or private equity
deployment i was in the world of hedge
funds before was to make this a vehicle
where the everyday citizen could
actually speak on their convictions and
to be able to do so with their own money
and therefore the optimal authority that
they bring to the boardroom or to the to
the capital markets that's part of what
i wanted to create i hope the everyday
citizen is able to participate in that
in whatever way makes sense for them we
launched our first exchange traded fund
for the u.s energy sector in august that
was a very simple message contained in
the ticker it was drl drill was the
ticker of that fund but there will be
more of these funds coming in the future
so that's what strive is bringing to the
table but miguel i just think that's a
that's a subset of a broader a broader i
think i i think obligation civic
obligation that any citizen has today
now more than ever to say that when you
find yourself
surrounded in a room or in a meeting or
in a culture where you believe you're
the only one who
has to say what you have to say
go ahead and speak up and say it and i
think that in the same way that fear has
been infectious over the last decade of
our of our cultural uh evolution i think
courage can be infectious over the next
decade as well and i'm really hopeful
that you know not only strive but
hopefully other actors and institutions
step up to the plate to create the
conditions for that revival of of
courage in our discourse
well i i think psychologically that your
solution is a very good one because part
of the problem with expecting people to
speak up is that they're caught in a
nexus of competing responsibilities yeah
so for example
my clients would before my clinical
practice precipitously collapsed because
of of the sorts of things that we're
talking about in no small part
uh i had many clients who were being
bullied by uh activist types who were
virtu virtue signaling and bullying them
at great personal expense
and many of them were loath to speak up
because they were afraid they would lose
their job or lose a promotion and they
had a family dependent on them and so
it wasn't exactly that they were
cowardly it was that they didn't want to
sacrifice
one set of virtues for another and
what i would do with those people is
come up with a very detailed medium to
long-term strategy to put them on firmer
ground financially
and practically so that they could
conceivably take the risk of speaking up
without
sacrificing their responsibility to the
people around them and you've done that
in some sense with this fund because you
enable people to make a bet with
something that's valuable which is a
cost and a risk and a real one without
simultaneously exposing them to the high
probability that their financial
viability will be uh
compromised in the future and so i i
think it's a lovely a lovely example of
a of a very intelligent partial solution
and that's what we want right a plethora
of optional partial solutions yes
there's no such thing as a singular
solution this is at best a partial
solution but i hope a partial solution
yeah and a plethora of partial solutions
might be our our best hope of
of uh getting to getting to some of the
places we've discussed we've we've
addressed this discussion and yeah well
that's what you sort of believe if
you're a free market person it's like
well what do we want a plethora of
possible solutions exactly
one of them might work
exactly and that shifts with time too so
for my part i'll write a couple of books
and start a company i hope somebody else
somebody else chooses to make their
contributions in a in a different way so
well well said thank you michaela thanks
for the opportunity yeah thank you very
much for for coming on and i will link
strive and i will link both of your
books in the show notes or the
description if anyone's interested in
checking them out and then uh do you
have websites or social media people can
follow
yeah strive.com is where strive is so
that's pretty easy uh i'm you know i i
my one social media that i that i use
relatively actively is on twitter i'm
you know at vivek d ramaswamy uh
vivekramaswamy.com is a website but uh
you know it's not uh there's not too
many vivek rama swami's floating around
so i won't be hard to find but uh but i
you know i'd love to i'd love to engage
in this play that that both of you
talked about with
anyone who reads the reads the works
that i put out anyone who's a who's a
client of strive or wants to be a client
of strive this is part of a broader play
between co-equal citizens and so you
know let's have at it please find me